[Musik]
Meditation im Weltraum Andres ogen Antioch
Tom Kite Partituren f ing schockierend - Lichter
Vox unter Bauch fest mr.  Anson über
Condesa Kurse an unserer Universität und
Spots wurden Unternehmen geschrieben: Selbst
saisonale Messwerte in unserem Kreis können
verwundet werden
Stören Sie den britischen
Historiker Theodore Selden Luftsäcke im
Mittelfeld über Indien unter
Erwähnung Harrison entfesselt in den
Millionen von Meditationen Kissin Settin im
Verkehr Shweta
in Zürich Tsongas frische Dosis, um
Roger Schmidt Richard Davidson zu fragen, dann
Anfänger, inshallah ist ein weiteres Feld und
Experte Wildbret Standard Gateway Shastri
Hakuna Matata  theone of the region und
unter einem Kuss auf hallo Todd hier ist der
Moment, der so von ihnen gegossen wurde, blonder grauer Baum,
noch in Nathan Byrne, wo Anna
Fortunes Risotto Ted vorhanden ist, aber er
hat noch nicht so gegossen eformula Fleisch
Fleischfresser Davidson erfahrener Professor
Physiologie Einschnitt  drei an der
Universität von Madison Wisconsin erfahren
und die eine Taste  Faktor Muncie Harness
Ocean of the Listed the Home, das ich
im College-Drachen in dieser Zeitmagazinwelle betont habe,
wenn ich einen Quittungsartikel verpasse, ist
es eine Freude, hier zu sein. Vielen
Dank, Amerikas einziger Stein Marissa
Kaboom-Clown, ernsthaft, Sie können nur
begrenzte T finden  on Ich glaube, dass
geistiges Training irgendwann genauso angesehen wird
wie körperliches
Training heute. In den meisten westlichen Ländern
verstehen die Menschen heute, dass körperliches
Training etwas Gutes für ihre Gesundheit ist, und
sie nehmen jede Woche an etwas teil, und
ich glaube  dass mentale Übungen einfache
Formen der Meditation heute so
häufig praktiziert werden wie körperliche Übungen,
sobald die Menschen erkennen, wie
wichtig es für ihren Geist sein kann, ihrem Gehirn zu
entkommen, können für
Montagsmeditationen einen Saginaw-Dienst in türkischem
Topf aufstellen und de Jäger-CDJ-
Meditationen ausstatten  Telefon von ähm, das ist aus der
Kunst- und Drachenmeditation, das ist Casa,
glaube fest, vermeide schwere Stürze von
Jon kabat-zin  n vitae and tröpfelt auf
soto sagon
papouli vereinbarung über jon kabat-zinn de
orphans in entfremdet von der philosophie,
also stimme über harlee akatsuki
monsanto ik verwickelt in den sind einige
drachen verdient Shonda trägt ein
mikrofon anna jon kabat-zinn
und erhält ahuyama zusammenfassung  vez esta
Zen-Meditation oder Yoga treffen Wesley Hamid
Es ist im Sofa Benton und 1979
klang es verrückt, als ob Sie wissen, dass ich
vielleicht wie ein drogenverrückter Hippie war, der
hereinkommt und nur Sie wissen
, dass Sie unethisch wissen, dass Sie das
Krankenhaus im Krankenhaus ausnutzen  Gesundheitssystem
nicht taub werden Ein geistloser Aguru sollte einen Donnerbeckenschacht
schnüffeln Liebes, keine
Hoffnungen Sie Hooligan Richard Davidson
begann den Oscar comin zur Meditation
des Skihügels und Sir Fortune, der
spektakuläre Reso Tartan
seine Kämpfer und gefürchtete Psyche tere
naina studium es Buddha Station Herrenhaus
macht legal Mesa Committee, dass bald die
Helms für ihn endeten, sobald sich die
Wissenschaft zu entwickeln begann, was
ich 1979 begann, es war ver  Es ist schwer
zu argumentieren, dass dies nicht
wertvoll sei, da wir nicht
nur anekdotische Beweise von medizinischen
Patienten mit vielen verschiedenen chronischen
Diagnosen hatten, sondern auch die
objektiveren wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse, dass dies
tatsächlich Ihre Physiologie
und Ihr Gehirn verändert  und
architektur und struktur die
unsolder studenten ultima ist ort ein fest
explodiert in gefühl und inhalt positive
wirkung der orgel ist muss man nicht fragen ahem
najib ist invadin indem er die
illegale nachricht midi reißt 'herren
in berlin zum ende omen beim regulan fest
unterschiedlich a  menschliche Kappa Babus Zeichen
in einer Bande mit einer Stimmung Shonans in
tausend Jahreszeit speisen Pfingstrose ivenna Haustor
das Haus per Kondom bearbeitet Zone von
Qian Jungs nicht kazan an ein Vermögen gebunden
sie hat Ninoy Löffel Volga durchgesickert
veränderte Eigenschaften und unanständige Lieder e
über berühmt  nambeesan brains und Vaslav
ottoman on gehörten dazu, dass der kann sich sogar
vorstellen varus ohne das symptom via
christi shot gut das ist av  Eine sehr
wichtige Frage, und wie Sie in
diesem neuen Buch mit Daniel Goleman bemerkt haben,
überprüfen wir die besten Forschungsergebnisse,
die in den USA zu Meditation und dem Titel des
Buches durchgeführt wurden.  Zumindest sind es veränderte
Eigenschaften, und was wir damit meinen, sind die
dauerhaften Veränderungen, die durch die Meditationspraxis erzeugt werden
, und es stellt sich heraus,
dass es nicht viele Studien gibt,
ernsthafte wissenschaftliche Studien, die wirklich
die Kriterien der Strenge erfüllen, die
dies untersucht und das festgestellt haben  Es
gibt tatsächlich dauerhafte Folgen, aber
was wir sehen, was die Beweise zeigen,
ist, dass es mehrere Bereiche gibt, in denen
die Ergebnisse ziemlich robust sind. Einer
davon ist die Aufmerksamkeit. Es steht außer Frage,
wie William James 1890 sagte, dass unsere
Aufmerksamkeit erzogen werden kann, wir können es
tatsächlich  lernen, unsere Fähigkeit zu verbessern
, unsere Aufmerksamkeit zu fokussieren, und wir können lernen
, unser Gedankenwandern zu verringern
, das können wir mit Übung tun,
und es gibt Schaltkreise im Gehirn, von denen
wir wissen, dass sie sich ändern, wenn wir anfangen, diese
Übungen zu machen, und die Forschung zeigt das  Es
braucht eigentlich gar nicht so viel, bis Sie
beginnen, Veränderungen zu sehen, nachdem Sie
nach 20 oder 30 Stunden kumulativer Übung beginnen können, Veränderungen im Gehirn zu sehen
Eis bedeutet dies
nicht, dass die Änderungen von Dauer sind,
sondern es bedeutet einfach, dass die Änderungen
ziemlich leicht auftreten können. Wir stellen fest, dass
es mehr Stunden der Übung bedarf, bis
diese Änderungen Teil der
neuen Grundlinie werden, um sozusagen ein
neues Set zu etablieren  Punkt für eine Person Ich brauche ein Visum
Sie brauchen irgendeinen Status Jurgen
Antineoplastik Essen Essen Sie eine Limonade für Salon
de Zaak Tuskegee und Dorfbauern
besuchen Omnimon Long einen Meditierenden Nahal
Takfir n erdachte seine Qual an einem Staatsbürger
in Bukarest, es ist nachteilig mental
wie ein Fitnessstudio  Erstens ist Keihin
Most leider nur Kolosser und
Mussolini-Form und Kongressmeister gut.
Ich sage oft, dass
Neuroplastizität bewusst oder unbewusst geschieht und die meiste
Zeit unser Gehirn von
Kräften um uns herum geformt wird, über die wir
wenig Kontrolle haben und die wir größtenteils nicht wahrnehmen
Einladung in dieser Arbeit ist, dass
wir tatsächlich mehr Verantwortung
für unser Gehirn übernehmen und unser Gehirn mit
Absicht formen können, indem wir uns gesund und gesund kultivieren
Positive Denkgewohnheiten stellt sich heraus,
dass sich unser Gehirn tatsächlich verändert, wenn wir uns auf diese mentalen
Praktiken einlassen, und zwar
zum Besseren, und es ist eine
Folge dieser Veränderungen im
Gehirn, die dann die Grundlage
oder Grundlage für dauerhafte Veränderungen
unserer Erfahrung bilden  und unser Verhalten, das davon
kam, ist schwer fassbar und hat den
Acanthamoeba-Namen Funes akkadian sogar einen
bloßen Schaden gefunden. Gut,
wir übernehmen die Verantwortung für uns, ja, aber
auf die gleiche Weise übernehmen wir die Verantwortung
für unseren Körper, wenn wir Sport treiben oder
überhaupt  von uns putzen unsere Zähne
mehrmals am Tag, es ist eine Art
persönliche Körperhygiene. Wir wissen,
dass dies wichtig ist, und wenn wir
wüssten, wie wertvoll unser Geist und
unser Gehirn für uns als
Menschen sind, würden wir unseren Geist in unserem
Gehirn pflegen  Genauso wie wir unsere Zähne pflegen, genauso wie wir uns
um unseren Körper kümmern,
und unsere Botschaft ist, dass dies
etwas Einfaches ist und es wirklich
ein Ur ist  Gent Public Health Need
It's Santini's New Reality of Our Tunes
in the Extreme Hawkinsville Endowment
Article – Raymond Dominguez Oktett
meditiert über Freund Künstler Leoben
gelöst und sogar Nische noch zu
Hause bleiben – Von diesem Akt an ist die Authentizität
des Maximums nicht jemand, der auch
jeden isst  Korb Ich sage Schmidt für Batum
sehr häuslicher Medici-Versuch endete für
Schmidt unsere ganze Sektion Elephone über
einige - Zeit genaues Detail Amerika und
über Ji-Hyun D Telomere in gefunden, was das
Feld der Kunst die Kunst- und Vize-Video-
Alton-Verbraucheraufgabe in unserem Clarence Tim
ganz sicher, und deshalb nur
einen Moment zurücktreten, all dies sind wichtige
Bereiche aktiven Forschungsinteresses, und
es gibt eine Menge Behauptungen,
die besonders in der populären Presse
über die Vorteile der Meditation aufgestellt werden, und
es ist wichtig, besonnen zu sein
Einige
dieser Behauptungen sind etwas zurückhaltend, und daher wird Meditation nicht
alle Krankheiten
heilen, für die sie nie als Heilmittel entwickelt wurde
Krankheiten, aber in Bezug auf Telomere haben
Sie zum Beispiel gefragt, dass
Telomere ein biologischer oder molekularer
Marker des Alterns sind, und wir alle
altern, das ist Teil unserer natürlichen Biologie, aber
die Frage ist wirklich, wie schnell
manche Menschen altern
Rückgänge in ihrer molekularen Maschinerie
und andere Menschen zeigen flachere
Rückgänge und es gibt einige Arbeiten, die
darauf hindeuten, dass Meditation die Veränderungsrate verlangsamen kann
und sie daher nicht umkehrt
, sondern nur die Rate verlangsamt, mit der
Telomere die
Sujini-Annalistik um ein bisschen verkürzen
disney peteandjayne ein unsinniger wunsch, einer person zu geben
, ich werde sehen, verdammt noch mal, ein hartnäckiges
nein, bis der tipp, zivilisation,
ein arzt, halte dich von tama, meditativer,
genauer fokus auf diese schwestern, NDA, uncie -
Ivan in ANBU, wie gelder in interviews investiert werden
, ist eitelkeit, sich zu treffen  Dalai
Lama de Thomas besucht Kmart Apokryphen
Zoo hat sie über Bräunung in Städten in
Lake Akan gelehrt wer sagt nicht von ganz Gotham, dass
es eine böse Hoffnung wird  1992
traf ich den
Dalai Lama zum ersten Mal auf unserem Markt in Nami,
und er bat mich und einige andere
Wissenschaftler, das Projekt zur
Erforschung von Veränderungen im Gehirn zu beginnen
, die bei fortgeschrittenen Praktizierenden
in seiner Tradition auftreten können, und er sehr
ermutigte mich, die Werkzeuge der modernen
Neurowissenschaft zu nutzen, um Qualitäten
wie Freundlichkeit und Mitgefühl zu untersuchen, zusätzlich
zum Studium der negativen Seite des Lebens,
denn bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatte ich
hauptsächlich Stress und Widrigkeiten,
Angst und Depression studiert, und er sagte,
warum nicht  Sie verwenden diese Werkzeuge, um
positive Eigenschaften zu studieren, und es war ein Weckruf,
und so traf ich ihn 1992 zum ersten Mal bei
dieser Begegnung und dann traf ich
ihn, der eine Beziehung begann.
Heutzutage sehe ich ihn drei- bis viermal im Jahr, aber
weiter  Bei einer anderen Gelegenheit, ein paar Jahre später, war
ich in seiner Residenz in Dharamsala, Indien,
und er hielt mich am Arm und sagte
auf sehr direkte Weise, er sagte, ich möchte, dass
Sie die Praktiken unserer Tradition übernehmen  Wenn Sie
sie in eine säkulare Form verwandeln, studieren Sie sie
im Labor mit den
strengsten Werkzeugen der modernen Wissenschaft, und wenn
Sie feststellen, dass sie von Nutzen sind,
verbreiten Sie sie weit,
und das war meine Aufgabe für den
Rest meines Lebens, zeevala unter meiner Überweisung
an Dean Indonesia  Mancha in Toss ma
eifriges Nettogeld abwechselnd Sie haben etwas
Würde
Kaena für Medici Herrenhaus in London
unmöglich selbstlos Irene ist nervig
Buchalter Trades sind drei Vega de
Medici eigene diese werden Skripte dann
Tiffin vage über das Skript Einladungswoche
auf Stefan
en en t Vega und  Sogar ihre intensiv
taglish Medici Amöbe erfüllen ein
yahren vet de tagging Eden hier unten und Roman
die NICHD und Vasavada Joaquin Sananda
Vikash Physiologische Verwirrung Parsons
Jameer und gegessen ungekocht Antonovitch
Gitarre Chaka Demus Montag Isaiah Langham
Adityan Synonyme sogar auf 20.000 gestohlen,
es ist ein Yogi der Verbreitung  Meditieren Sie,
verstehen Sie die Depressionsaffäre, und dies ist in
mir Australien eine Art, die in die Zyste gefallen ist
gerechter Ehrgeiz zu Stevens
Verluste geschlagen eine Person anderer Meinung mal versuchen
mittelalterliche Fatima meditieren finden Sie das
soziale Netzwerk heraus
ja, das ist eine sehr wichtige Frage
und etwas, das wir sehr ernst genommen haben, also haben wir sie
sehr langfristig untersucht, als wir mit dieser Arbeit begannen
Praktizierende, die jahrelang
meditiert haben, und wir haben uns dafür entschieden,
denn wenn wir keinen Unterschied in ihrem Gehirn finden könnten, wäre
die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
einen Unterschied bei jemandem zu finden, der
für eine viel kürzere Zeit meditiert
, undenkbar, und das
wollten wir  Beginnen Sie mit diesen sehr
langjährigen Praktizierenden, um zu sehen, ob
da etwas war, und wir stellten fest, dass
da etwas war, und das
ermutigte uns, dann mehr Kurzzeitpraktizierende zu studieren
, und mit
Praktizierenden, die wirklich gerade erst
anfangen, können wir tatsächlich
strengere Nachforschungen anstellen, weil  Wir können
Menschen zufällig einem Zustand zuordnen, in dem
sie lernen zu meditieren, und anderen
Arten von Interventionen, in denen sie nicht
meditieren  Dies ermöglicht eine viel
strengere wissenschaftliche Kontrolle, und in dieser
Art von
Studien haben wir dokumentiert, dass Sie
nach nur
sieben Stunden Übungsverbreitung
und auf Entwürfen auf einer losen Kanone Imam
Ali Veränderungen im Gehirn sehen können, deshalb unterschreibe ich Newton oder  Akita,
so Hanim in diesem Turm, Diamanten, rund, Blutmonde,
ja nun, das ist eine
großartige Frage, und die ehrliche Antwort
darauf ist, dass wir es nicht wissen, und es ist wahrscheinlich,
dass es für verschiedene Menschen unterschiedlich ist, und
daher ist es unsere Vermutung, wenn
Sie sagen, ob  Sie werden jeden
Tag 30 Minuten zum Üben aufwenden. Ist es besser
, in einer 30-Minuten-Periode in
drei 10-Minuten-Perioden oder zehn
Drei-Minuten-Perioden zu üben
?  meditiere über
Lichter ein Ticket estar fühle mich glücklich
Ultima Neuroenhancement auf Vanneman doch
Gazettes Standard auf Land Ines taka
Smith Canyon Invasion Wähler Nation
Stimuli besitzt er einen 9-Punkte-Bringin in
den Mestizen  Selbst auf 20.000
Steinmeditation und Russell Shank klickte auf
Visita Spucke, dann bestehen Sie darauf, dass
es nicht Wochen wieder dauert, oder besuchen Sie die Sendung, die ich
früher gestohlen und auf ihn und so Harlan gerockt habe,
wenn es wirklich wahr wäre, dass eine
bestimmte Form der Neurostimulation
perfekt wäre  Replizieren Sie die Veränderungen
im Gehirn, die wir mit langfristiger
Meditationspraxis sehen, und Sie können dann
die Art von dauerhaften Veränderungen
schnell erreichen, warum tun Sie das nicht? Ich bin zutiefst
skeptisch als jemand, der
Neurowissenschaftler ist
denke, dass wir eigentlich genug über
die Veränderungen im Gehirn wissen, dass wir
diese Veränderungen durch Neurostimulation hervorrufen können.
Ich kann Ihnen heute mit viel
Zuversicht sagen, dass wir das nicht tun
können
Öl,
es ist einfach nicht wahr, es sind die
Veränderungen, die wir im Gehirn sehen,
viel komplexer, viel komplizierter,
und daher gibt es zum gegenwärtigen
Zeitpunkt keinen Ersatz für Übung, Sie
kennen den Dalai Lam  a scherzte mit uns und er
sagte, wenn Sie mir eine Pille geben könnten,
die mein Mitgefühl grenzenlos steigern würde
, oder wenn Sie eine
Neurochirurgie durchführen und einen Teil meines
Gehirns verändern könnten, der mein Mitgefühl steigern
würde, würde ich es sofort bei
jedem Vashti tun  entkommt absolut seiner Farm
und seinem Visionsschacht letzte Meldung Anisha
Africa Forensic Services Bestechung einer
Herstellerflagge es geht um Mohini
Flucht Schwester Flightmare spiritueller
Künstler Odysseus Odyssee Ich kann sagen, dass unsere
Tomcats-Meditation auf eine Treppe kommt Eber
sagte von der Spottywot-Sati auf Sati ist
kein Anti-Elise  Saguna Edelen bat
ausländischen Vaters auf Dahveed Ammoniaktank
Ania
Meditation ist taktil und ist ständige
spirituelle Prozesse auf dem Gemetzel in
medialer O'Donnell und Emma Watson
Einrichtung in nahen und fernen Quellen auf einer
Flucht des Homo und den zu arbeitenden
Besuchern alles Mitgefühl habe ich ein anderes
Denken Sie daran, Alison Stevens TCH
spirituell Palästina von einer unangenehmen Stelle
am Tatort zu sehen. Ich weiß, dass ich das sehr
unterschreibe, und  Ich denke, dass
es bestimmte sehr wichtige
Eigenschaften gibt, die Teil der
traditionellen klassischen Literatur über
Meditation sind, die Meditation in
einen viel größeren Rahmen einbetten, und es ist wirklich
eine Weltanschauung und es ist auch ein ethischer
Rahmen, so dass, wenn wir unseren
Hintern auf das Kissen legen oder  Auf einem Stuhl zu
meditieren, meditieren wir nicht nur für
uns selbst, sondern rufen tatsächlich die
Absicht hervor, die Ihren Geist beruhigt
und unser Herz geöffnet hat, in erster Linie zum
Wohle anderer, nicht für uns selbst, und
daher gibt es eine altruistische Motivation
, die dafür so wichtig ist und  Ich
denke also, dass
es wichtiger ist als die eigentlichen
Meditationstechniken selbst. Es wurde
nie studiert, das ist eine andere Sache
, die wir in unserem Zentrum aktiv studieren,
aber das sind alles wirklich
wichtige Teile des spirituellen Weges,
und ich denke  dass es
tatsächlich in wissenschaftlich handhabbare Fragen zerlegt werden könnte
, so dass es sich um Fragen handelt,
die wirklich könnten  studiert werden und sie
deuten sicherlich darauf hin, dass
der Pfad viel mehr beinhaltet als die einfachen
Meditationstechniken selbst, die
bisher die wissenschaftliche
Forschung auf diesem Gebiet dominiert haben
SRP für Disney Novartis
Fatima Tanked Hunter namens in der Karre
ist kuzey ungeschlagen in unserem Sankara Meta
Biden und Oscars gehandelt hat ihn nicht bekommen
Garnierung Tom es verwirren cool tavira Nora
Dimension Lakritze Beschreibung eines
Humvee in wütender Klitoris Leben Sohn fragte
es und kehrt zurück  strapazierfähiges
Aluminium-Design und geschnittene Plastik-
Pullover Biani vervollständigt in den
Wochen des Jahres absolute Carlton Rand des
Systems in der Amira und für ihre Leute
Lügen drehen sich noch nicht um
Thailands Kritiker haben es nicht als
Honigbiene gesehen  Fujitora Tenkan Z-9 wurde von
mir übersehen, also denke ich, dass Sie
ein sehr wichtiges Thema ansprechen, und ich
habe meiner Erfahrung nach eine sehr breite Palette von
Ansätzen gesehen  ches in der Unternehmenswelt,
die in Bezug auf
Achtsamkeit und andere verwandte Arten von
Praktiken verwendet wurden, einige würde ich in die
Kategorie einordnen, die Sie beschrieben haben, wo die
Einführung dieser Praktiken
wirklich ziemlich ist, würde ich sagen, kalt und ein bisschen
manipulativ und
wirklich gerade erst ankommend  Arbeitnehmer
sollen stressresistenter und
in der Situation, in der sie sich befinden, vollständig mitschuldig sein,
aber ich habe andere in anderen
Unternehmenssektoren gesehen
Führungskräfte, wo sie
erkennen, dass Mitarbeiter, die zur
Arbeit erscheinen und glücklich sind, tatsächlich
allen zugute kommen, es ist gut für ihr
Leben, aber es hat auch einen positiven
Einfluss auf ihre Arbeitsmoral, es
wirkt sich positiv auf andere aus, die sie
eher engagieren  Es ist weniger
wahrscheinlich, dass die Mitarbeiterbindung
höher ist, und es gibt viele, viele Vorteile
, die sich daraus ergeben, und es könnte
wirklich eine Win-Win-Situation sein, die viele er manövriert haben  Klicke auf
memiliki k9, dann hoffe ich, dass er
Vania SMERSH letztendlich weinerlich macht. Sie
behalten eine gewisse Affinität. Saudis haben eine FAQ auf
ihrer Seite.
Es ist das Zeichen, dass es schon gut ist. Das Problem
der Leute, die sagen, dass sie keine
Zeit haben, ist sicherlich etwas, das ich habe
viele Male gehört, und in unserem Zentrum
sind wir jetzt an einem sehr groß angelegten
Projekt beteiligt, um diese
Methoden zunächst am Arbeitsplatz zu verbreiten. Es ist
Teil einer Initiative, die wir die
Initiative für gesunde Köpfe nennen, und es ist
teilweise eine digitale Plattform, die wir
entwickeln  Aber es sind auch andere
Komponenten, die eine persönliche
Komponente beinhalten, aber einer der wichtigen
Ausgangspunkte dafür ist, wenn eine Person
uns sagt, dass sie absolut keine
Zeit übrig hat, und den Gedanken daran hat, sich an
einer Übung zu beteiligen, um ihr zu helfen und
ihren Stress zu reduzieren  wird sie
angesichts des Lebens, das sie führen, nur noch gestresster machen,
und was wir sagen, ist in Ordnung,
Sie müssen kein einziges X
an Ihrem Tag widmen, nicht eine Minute, aber Sie können
immer noch meditieren und er  Wir haben
sie gebeten, einige
Aktivitäten des täglichen Lebens zu nominieren, die nicht
kognitiv anspruchsvoll sind, und wir alle haben
das Pendeln, das Haus putzen,
das Geschirr spülen, die Wäsche waschen,
was auch immer es sein mag, und wir sagen ihnen, dass wir es
in dieser Zeit tun  Ich werde Ihnen
einige einfache Übungen geben, die Sie tun können, die Sie sich anhören können.
Sie müssen sich nichts ansehen.
Sie können einfach zuhören und eine
geführte Übung durchführen. So können Sie dies tun,
während Sie andere
Dinge tun  Medicare und
Abtreibung werden zu Tinnitus. Nun, es ist
Meditation, während Sie sich mit
Aktivitäten des täglichen Lebens beschäftigen,
und es geht wirklich darum, wie Sie
sich zeigen
und wie gut Ihr Bewusstsein ist, und wie einige Meditationslehrer
das grundlegende
Merkmal beschrieben haben, das alle Formen vereint  der
Meditation ist ein Fokus auf das Bewusstsein
Gäste Inversionen Entscheidungen gewalttätig Avex
unordentlich Binaca sprach, dass Jesus
uns gibt mir ist schwindelig schwindelig großartig kaity omitsu
to can't see moment of S  usan c koch
- wartete so ständig und
schwierig auf die werke und susan einige
religionen in der bailout-bash wohnten in der
herrschenden unterernährten lass uns entlassen
tobiah spitzengericht gitarrenbecher aphrodite unsere
nominierte telomere aveda ehrgeiz langa auf
dem aufsteigen erster ehrgeiz intuition
doppelte kunst sagte er zu dem  willkürlich
und David aufrichtig eine Basis mr.  Chaddha
verschwand und Bikini-Talent auf Soutane-
Converse befürchtet keine Nebenwirkung auf dem
Land, auch die Mondsteinkrankheit,
und Susan kann es mit Sicherheit nicht sehen
, das ist eine sehr wichtige Beobachtung, und
was ich sagen würde, ist, das einfach zu bemerken
und als Unterstützung zu nutzen  Ihr
Bewusstsein alles könnte als
Unterstützung für Ihr Bewusstsein verwendet werden, also beachten
Sie, dass Sie von den Gedanken abgelenkt wurden,
dass es nützlich sein könnte,
aber behandeln Sie sie
nicht anders als jede andere Art von
Gedanken, sie sind nur Gedanken und
so weiter  Gut, hängen Sie einfach nicht an
ihnen, aber Sie wissen, dass der Dalai Lama
mir gesagt hat, dass er manchmal, wenn er sich
zum Üben hinsetzt, darüber nachdenkt, dass
er sein Gehirn verändert, und das
gibt ihm tatsächlich eine gewisse Motivation, also ist daran
nichts auszusetzen,
solange  da man damit nicht zu eng
wird. Buddha-Tölpel sind heute los, er hat
über Kris-Terminals und Rabatte zur Unterdrückung des gemeinsamen Dasya abgeschlagen.
Wir bleiben bei Zen
the Smitha Field School TV oder neun
Zählungen  Vista beste Anti-Dzasta-Meditation
auf Spanisch auf digitalen Matratzen in
Seeland verankert und Rajesh Mishra
vermitteln einen Anstand Tatiana und vor allem
Lhasa war es der herrische Alpha-Koch Nick, wir
klicken auf DD-Meditation in der politischen
Linie.
Ich denke, das ist für wirklich schwierige
Konfliktzonen der Welt  Meine eigene
Perspektive ist, dass wir
mit der jüngeren Generation beginnen müssen, die noch
nicht polarisiert ist, und Sie wissen, dass es
wirklich gute Forschung gibt, hartnäckige Forschung,
die sehr stark darauf hindeutet, dass jeder
Mensch mit einer Neigung zur Warmherzigkeit auf die Welt kommt
pro  -soziales Verhalten und Freundlichkeit, dies ist
Teil dessen, was wir als Menschen sind, und
wenn wir die Möglichkeit haben, eine Wahl zu treffen, werden
wir die kooperative,
prosoziale und freundliche Alternative wählen,
anstatt die, die egoistisch und
aggressiv und sehr ist  Kleinkinder zeigen
diese Neigung, und wenn wir also
über Meditation sprechen, um Mitgefühl zu kultivieren,
sprechen wir nicht darüber, irgendeinen
Zustand in der Seele zu schaffen  Geist de novo aus dem
Nichts, sondern wir sprechen vielmehr davon
, eine Qualität zu erkennen,
die von Anfang an vorhanden war, und sie zu
fördern, und es ist sehr ähnlich, wie
Wissenschaftler die Sprache sehen, für die jeder Mensch
mit einer biologischen Fähigkeit auf die Welt kommt
Sprache, aber diese Fähigkeit erfordert,
dass wir in einem normalen Englisch in der Gemeinschaft erzogen werden,
wenn wir und es Fälle von
wilden Kindern gibt, die in
freier Wildbahn aufwachsen und die Sprache nicht
normal entwickeln, und deshalb denke ich, wenn wir mit
der jüngeren Generation beginnen und
diese Qualitäten bei sehr kleinen Kindern zu kultivieren und sie zu
stärken, unsere Aussichten für die
Welt werden sich dramatisch verbessern,
und das ist einer der Gründe, warum sich ein Großteil unserer
Arbeit heutzutage auf Bildung konzentriert,
einschließlich der sehr frühen Bildung, und
tatsächlich konzentriert sich unsere jüngste Arbeit
darauf  pränatale Einflüsse die Aufmerksamkeit
eligio nicht Karate-Telefone oder Englisch
Druck und Film get psyched meet mit dem
Titel Sicher gibt es einige Drachen,
die nicht schaden können  Videokunst auf Drachen in
Shaolin Ich war in aktuellen
Meditationen, denn wenn Sie sich irgendwie wie
Constance fühlen Lucia, die ich nicht kenne, diskutieren Sie
Produktflucht Misrata nach Hause auf der
Hyun-Soo Trainieren Sie in
der Tierpsychiatrie auf der Ji Heon für Vitamine Gitarrenstadt
- I  führte bei Sultan Leones Fanhaus-Dinner Davidson einen Vektor la Senora
phonons to bison wolf ein. Nun,
ich
würde sagen, es geht nicht so sehr darum
, sich fernzuhalten, sondern vielmehr unsere
Beziehung zu negativen Erfahrungen zu ändern, damit
Widrigkeiten passieren, von denen keiner von uns
vollständig gepuffert werden kann  Widrigkeiten
Leiden ist Teil des menschlichen Lebens, und so werden
wir alle leiden, es liegt in der
Natur einer menschlichen Geburt, und daher ist die Frage,
wie wir mit Leiden umgehen, wie wir
mit Widrigkeiten umgehen, und eine der
wichtigen Fähigkeiten, die Sie erwerben, wenn
Sie  Sich auf diese Praktiken einzulassen, ist
Resilienz, und Sie können lernen, sich schneller zu erholen
, und das ist etwas, das
für das Wohlbefinden wirklich wichtig ist
lcome danke
oh Meditation Entwickler Mann komm
Theater Zelle Indonesien Trajektorie
Verkehr ist Zeug gehalten ish
sie sind ziemlich sicher historisch sind
sie lange beiseite Differenzen werden gegeben für
Shiden eine Provision und ein Mubarak nicht
gesaugt Meditation Lanka den Ziegel M & R
in Tisch Alligatoren ruhig
Torrents lebt in Darrell mm am Anfang
mit unter der Villa
[Musik]
Aamir's seine Schulden
Theodore Selden emeriti der Professor für
Effizienz an der Universität in Oxford
gibt Oktoberherzen oft im
Turnier McKeon's Organismen Yunnan OS
eine Einnahme stellt mi vida cryptic red vor
in meditationslöffelhaltung zum
harlem sind die kinder nicht
wiederholt Ich hatte nur einmal einen satz
darüber, als ich über
etwas ganz anderes sprach und
sofort hat der journalist, der ein
sklave dieser besonderen mmm keine therapie war
, es in die zeitungen gebracht und ich fühle mich
Darüber denke ich auf die gleiche Weise wie über
Lebensmittel, wenn Sie etwas zu essen kaufen,
möchten Sie wissen, wo  Es kommt von Ihnen,
wissen Sie, welche Art von Erde kam, welche es produzierte,
welche Art von Pestiziden darin
enthalten waren und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter,
woher kommt es,
zuerst einmal, es kommt aus dem Buddhismus,
aber es ist kein Buddhismus im selben Bild
Wenn Sie in ein indisches Restaurant gehen und
essen, bekommen Sie kein indisches Essen, sondern
eine verwestlichte Version des indischen Essens,
und so ist dies eine verwestlichte Version,
die für den Kapitalisten und für
diejenigen, die dafür bezahlen, akzeptabel gemacht wird, und zweitens ist es
so  wurde durch die Leute
, die es in die westliche Welt einführten, stark verändert,
als ein kritischer, sehr beschäftigter Mann in einem
neuen Inseltelefon über die Bedeutung eines
gasförmigen Mittels auf einem Bischof - unbestreitbar war
Kazu-Staub in Chilis und Harvey-
Furnier ein Kritiker mit vielen Fehlinformationen  von
neun Gedanken über Pazifismus, die bald bearbeitet werden,
Lincoln, den ich von ihnen führen kann, von
der Zelle ist mehr in einen Ton durch
Meditation, Willia, eine Ganesha-Konstante,
bald, ja, gut, lassen Sie mich mit
dem zweiten Platz fortfahren  Der Ort, von dem es
kam, ist derselbe Ort wie Facebook, nämlich die
Harvard University und David
und Goldman und all diese Leute trafen sich an der
Harvard University, gerade als ich
damals Gastprofessor in Harvard war und
es damals Studenten und viele Leute
gab  Die 70er, frühen 70er waren verlorene, verlorene
Seelen, und sie gingen nach Indien in der
Hoffnung, Erlösung zu finden, und sie waren
begeistert, weil es neu war, und
sie brachten es zurück und sagten, mein zweiter
Kommentar ist, dass es von den Sorgen
der 1970er und seitdem kommt  50 Jahre Single
haben sich so sehr verändert, wie Sie wissen, wir haben uns
von der Produktion auf dem
Festland zu einer Morris-Dienstleistungsgesellschaft
gewandelt, und wir haben unsere Bevölkerung verdoppelt,
wir haben neue Sorgen um
die Umwelt und so weiter und so die
Konzentration auf die Ideen, die  die
im alten Buddhismus existierten, sind nicht so
auf unsere eigene Zeit
anwendbar  nds beschädigt, wie ich
merke, es ist unermesslich cool ein gutartiges
Campostella versteckt für den Handel mr.  Aziz
Argan ist dankbar für ehrliche Feindseligkeit.
Anikas heikle Aktivitäten sind das ultimative
Mineral. Also, wie hat der bescheidene Jota
mit den Meditationen begonnen. Jemandes Schlüssel
zu meiner Aufgabe ist
Eliquis  Der
Zweck dieser Meditation ist es, sich auf sich selbst zu konzentrieren,
auf Ihre Atmung im Moment,
in dieser gegenwärtigen Zeit, und für mich ist das
keine Art der Konzentration, es
lenkt Sie von allem anderen ab,
es gibt keine Konzentration, das
Gegenteil von Konzentration,
Konzentration bedeutet die Fähigkeit dazu  Schauen Sie
sich jeden Aspekt des Lebens an und sehen Sie, wie sie
interagieren. Die Fähigkeit, Nachrichten zu empfangen
und in Ihrem Gehirn zu interagieren und
Ihr Gehirn dazu zu bringen, über dem einfachen Stehplatz Ihres Kunden zu funktionieren
, denn wenn Sie
sich einige kürzlich veröffentlichte Statistiken ansehen
, gibt es 8 Prozent der
Amerikaner  tun Achtsamkeit und acht
Prozent der Amerikaner nehmen Beruhigungsmittel
und Antidepressiva und was diese kürzlich durchgeführte
Umfrage herausgefunden hat  war das die Leute die
Antidepressiva nehmen von manchmal
fünf Jahren nehmen sie Prozac und solche
Sachen und die kommen da nicht
raus und es hat sich noch niemand angeschaut
was mit den Leuten passiert die
die nächsten 20 Jahre Achtsamkeit machen und
ob  Die Ganges sind gerade
süchtig danach geworden, über ihre Atmung nachzudenken,
und in diesem Moment sage ich
, das ist sehr lobenswert, dass das, was
sie tun, sehr lobenswert ist, sie
wollen Schmerzen und Leiden lindern und so weiter
, das ist sehr gut, aber was
passiert  Jetzt können wir die Neugier gebrauchen,
die die
großen Denker der Vergangenheit, die großen
Musiker, die großen Künstler,
auf die Welt geschaut und gesagt haben: Nein, die Welt ist
nicht, was sie ist, und wir müssen entdecken, was
wir nicht dürfen  Versuchen Sie, normal und ruhig
und zufrieden zu sein. Natürlich ist es sehr gut,
dass Menschen durch Regierungen
zufrieden sind, und Cameron, der
Premierminister von Großbritannien, hat Geld für
Achtsamkeit und all das gegeben  Damit
die Menschen zufrieden sein und die Klappe halten sollen,
passiert nicht so eine Revolution
Rhodesians II, das ist richtig,
du hast absolut recht, und
Sugata selbst sagte, wenn du nichts
über mich wissen willst, weil ich wütend werden
würde, würde ich weglaufen, wenn ich etwas über mich selbst wüsste, und
du kannst dich selbst nicht kennen, weil ein Teil von
dir davon abhängt  darüber, was andere Leute
über dich denken und du hast Illusionen
über dich selbst, wenn du nein magst, bin ich
von dieser Buchhalterin genervt, Kritik an den
Meditationen, Vivian war großartig, M&Z,
ja, der HD Woodson, Alexejewna, Mann, aus
diesem Gericht bricht Goldman Aravind,
es ist auch ein Nebentäter  Ihre
emotionale und Intelligenz, die vor
allem nicht mit Richard Davidson so
Lachs Kumpel
Hahn Tatsuya D in den Medien ist, um jetzt
wahrscheinlich hobb Maßstab zu bestimmen  Es ist sogar schwer
für ihn, Richard Davidson zu treffen, der orcischen
Teil gehörte und Zargon D. Biden schüttelte Recht
All die
Werke dieser Leute sind, dass sie
nichts über die Welt aussagen, außer dass sie
sie verändern werden, das heißt, woher weißt du
, wie die Welt ist? Ich bin tatsächlich ein
Beispiel dafür, dass sie große Bewunderer
des Dalai Lama waren  ein Mann, der alles sagt,
was den Amerikanern gefällt,
und ein sehr charmanter Mann, aber er ist ein
Anführer im Exil, und wenn er zurückgeht,
vorausgesetzt, Tibet wird befreit und
unabhängig, und er der eigentliche
Anführer wird, der er nicht
mehr sein will  ein politiker und
politiker haben kein leichtes leben und
die beziehungen bedeuten theologie und
machtpolitik immer reibungen und daher denke ich, dass
genau das, was in der meditation fehlt, die
unwissenheit über alles ist  Was
in der Welt vor sich geht,
und der einzige Weg, wie Sie das herausfinden können,
besteht darin, dorthin zu gehen und
mit verschiedenen Arten von Menschen zu sprechen und zu
sehen, dass es so kompliziert ist, dass
Sie die Welt nicht
ändern können  In der Punkrock-Ära
werfen Steckdosen in meine Philosophie oder
Freunde, die leicht zu sehen sind, betrachtet auch
Universitäten, in denen sich die effiziente
historische Entwicklung und das Echo des
historischen Ereignisses veranstalten, in dem ich in Havanna Man-Thong
als Bösewicht Katana genau Spinning
Esterline-Vereinbarungen dort in einer Art Box war
- Tech-Reise  was vielleicht so seine
Gedanken sind, eine andere halbe indische Philosophie,
Ganzi Atlas war wirklich auf einer Mission,
ruht, mütterliche Depression, fang an, zu
meditieren, Missin, Dorf, Druckkraftstoff,
Vaska, jetzt ist die Koons-Anzeige, eine Art von
uns, Leinwandanzeige, erster Emeritus, den er
entfesselt hat  zu sagen, was
von ihm erwartet wurde, die meisten Leute konnten nicht
sehr gut sprechen, und es gibt immer noch viele
Leute, die nicht ver sprechen können  Nun, und
eines der Dinge, die ich kürzlich entdeckt habe, war
, mit Leuten zu sprechen, die Kindern helfen,
und sie sagten mir, diese Kinder
haben nie mit ihren Familien gesprochen,
sie sitzen vor diesem Fernseher und sie
sitzen mit ihren eigenen Telefonen, wissen Sie, und
sie haben sie nicht  zu sprechen, sie wissen nicht,
wie man sich unterhält, und wie lernt man sich zu
unterhalten, indem man Älteste um sich herum hat, die
sich über interessante Dinge unterhalten und
die einem beigebracht haben, sich zu unterhalten, und Menschen
in der Vergangenheit schämten sich zu sprechen,
weil sie nicht gut mit dir sprechen konnten
wissen, dass sie wie gebildete Menschen sprechen können,
also ist dies eine neue Sache, um zu lernen, wie man sich
unterhält. Es war auf sehr wenige Menschen beschränkt,
und viele Menschen, die behaupten, sich zu
unterhalten, gehen tatsächlich zu Monologen,
und nur Sie wissen, wie Politiker im
Alter sprechen und nicht.  Wir müssen nicht zuhören und deshalb müssen
wir lesen, wir entdecken nicht die
vergangenen Gespräche wieder, sondern erfinden ein neues
Gespräch. Sehen Sie, tausend zu haben, ist
die Oxford News Foundation, die auf dieser Grundlage empfohlen wird,
dies ist Steve
Kent  ucky das gleiche Darwin-Design auf dem
Mondzeichen Kernan auf
tasveer Mahnwache und erneuter Unterricht diskreditieren Sufian
Körperdiskussion hier ist Ihr erster
Moment, in dem sie jede Drift
zerstört, Anklage Robbie souffl,
außer sich zu sonnen, eingeladen vermarktet wird,
erfuhren wir, und dann um
Alessandra, die von dieser Anzeige erwähnt wurde,
trifft  ein paar Ich bringe niemandem
etwas bei,
ich lasse sie von sich selbst lernen, und
was ich tue, ist wichtig zu wissen,
worüber Sie sprechen und worüber die Leute
gerne sprechen, sind sie selbst, und das
große Problem für sie ist, dass sie es nicht
finden können  jeder, der ihnen zuhört, aber ich gebe
ihnen diese Gelegenheit, und was ich tue, ist, dass ich
jeden einlade, der kommen möchte, und
ich habe Arbeitslose eingeladen
, die gerade ins Gefängnis gekommen sind,
bis ich es in der Schweiz und in Davos getan habe
im Weltwirtschaftsforum und ich
habe auch die reichsten Menschen der
Welt und ich bringe Leute dazu, andere zu treffen,
die sie normalerweise nicht treffen,
und ich habe zum Beispiel eingeschlossen, dass ich
türkisches Peo habe  Bitte sprechen Sie mit Armeniern
mit den Köpfen, und die Antwort ist,
ihnen zu sagen, lassen Sie sie über Dinge sprechen, die
ihnen wichtig waren und was
ihnen wichtig ist, ihre Beziehungen zu
ihren Familien, ihre Freunde, Einsamkeit,
Schwierigkeiten bei der Arbeit, Sie wissen alles
, was Probleme mit Kindern hat  Wissen Sie,
das sind die menschlichsten Dinge, und
wenn Sie den Leuten das geben, was ich tue,
gebe ich ihnen ein Menü, mm-hmm, wie wenn Sie
in ein Restaurant gehen, haben Sie ein Menü auf meiner
Speisekarte, es ist arrangiert, Sie kennen das Fleisch-
Fisch-Dessert und so  aber unter jedem habe
ich verschiedene Fragen und dieses Buch,
das ich gerade geschrieben habe, enthält viele
Fragen, über die man auch sprechen kann,
die allgemeine Fragen sind, über die
alle reden müssen, und man
vermeidet Politik und Wirtschaft
und man vermeidet all das  Sprechen
Sie einfach darüber, woran Sie wirklich denken,
aber was sie alle sagen, wenn sie kommen,
dass wir nie die Gelegenheit haben,
dies zu tun  Druck er neun
bringen Industrie besitzt Resilienz Otesaga
Earthman und Englisch frisch besitzt oft
Schnäppchen Blitz gemeinsame Zoo-Metapher
Ausdruck, der im Invictus-
Design glänzte Was passiert, ist
in der Konversation, was die Leute zu
mir sagen und was sie nach dieser Konversation schreiben,
ist, dass ich so viel gelernt habe
über mich selbst als nur die andere Person,
weil ich gezwungen war, Dinge zu erklären,
die ich vorher nie klar ausgedrückt
hatte, und diese Gespräche
wurden mit Menschen aller Berufe geführt und
sie wurden in Unternehmen geführt,
damit Menschen innerhalb des Unternehmens
einander besser kennenlernen und wir
tun es nicht zwischen Leuten in verschiedenen
politischen Parteien, die Sie kennen, und ich möchte, dass
die Leute, die Trump unterstützen, und die
Leute, die Trump hassen, miteinander sprechen,
damit wir herausfinden, was wirklich
wichtig ist, weil im  bei der
abstimmung wählen die menschen aus allen möglichen gründen, aber
beim brexit geht es zum beispiel nicht wirklich um europa, sondern um den schmerz, unter dem
die
menschen leiden  In ihrem Privatleben
sieht man den Mangel an Erfüllung, Simon und ich
kennen Stella, die in einer Couscous-Pause werfen
und mit Arista gong-gong mit
Baumwolle arbeiten, dann werden
Giuk im wöchentlichen Rückblick auf Amaravathi
Tausend als Kardinäle und
entwaffnete Assistenten und den Speicherplatz an Clickin Zika geheftet
So enorm emotional ist die Clarion
Illinois Baumwolle wie der Gebärmutterhals und das
ist Qual in Volkers Kathaheim,
die ein Menschenschwänze zu Tausenden über ein
Jahrzehnt an Sorgen steht Armin also in
Dallas Fensterbauer Vaska jetzt sicher
diverse - und ein Quartett / oft
Indien ärgern  Schlechter Ausgang Beitrag Ausgang Sie können die
Argumentation herunterkommen G - 15
Iannetta ändert sich jeder weiß - Valen
Ja, ich sage zuallererst, ich möchte, dass die
Leute entdecken, wie schwierig oder
komplex jeder normale Mensch ist
Medizin konzentriert sich auf Menschen, die krank sind,
aber Menschen sind  nicht schlecht, noch
komplizierter, weil es so viele
Dinge in einem Gehirn gibt, wie ich ein
Gehirn beschrieben habe oder wie ein Antiquitätenladen
voller allerlei s
Du kennst Vorurteile aus vielen
Jahrhunderten, Ideen, Aberglauben und so weiter,
die jeder hat und ich weiß nicht,
welche Sammlung von Schrott du in
deinem Gehirn hast,
klobiges Gehirn, was für Bücher du
gelesen hast, welchen Senf, verschiedene Bücher, die
ich habe.  Ich habe gelesen, dass Sie wissen, welche Einflüsse das hat,
was Ihr Großvater Ihnen erzählt und so
weiter und so weiter zu entdecken, dass jede Person
ein Geheimnis entdeckt, und es ist ein
faszinierendes Geheimnis, und wenn
ich Sie kennenlerne, ist es eine wahre Freude für mich,
weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich  Ich entdecke die Welt,
einen nach dem anderen, einen nach dem anderen, entdecke
die Welt nicht in Bezug auf ein System, das
besagt, dass jeder dies oder jenes ist, aber
ich kenne Ikata immer noch sehr gut, also Atrus V CC und
sogar ein Stinkerspritzer, omnes, wie viele
glatt und klobig mein Name ist  Er stellt
sich Addison vor. Devel mm Ehrlich, das ist richtig
und warum habe ich diese Wohltätigkeitsorganisation, die
ich gegründet habe, die Muse Mus II genannt, weil
die Muse das ist, was alle Dichter gerne haben
, die sie inspiriert, und ich erwarte nicht
, Sie zu bekehren, ich don
Ich möchte Sie nicht zu etwas bekehren, das ich nicht predige oder
Sie so überreden, dass die Achtsamkeit
sagt, wir werden Sie heilen.
Ich bin kein
Therapeut  Mein Kopf wird
in deinem Kopf landen und wir werden in den
Müll sitzen und wir werden dir auch nützlich sein können,
sogar Muhsin InDesign macht
es fertig. Die Ohren einer Frau zeigen
eine verschüttete
Entscheidung  - Gewalt ausdehnen - gib
mir Weisheit, deshalb ist es nett, das meiste
englische Brot kann mu zan gurren, es ist
deine Schuld, wenn du dich langweilst ja ja,
weil du nicht genau genug hinsiehst,
denkst du nicht intensiv genug darüber nach,
warum diese Person dich langweilt
und ich spreche zum Beispiel mit Leuten
, die dafür gestimmt haben, Europa zu verlassen.
Es ist wirklich sehr interessant, dass einige sehr
intelligente Leute gewählt haben und einige arme
Leute, die nur dachten, dass es
die Welt in irgendeiner Weise verbessern würde, und sie
dachten nicht, dass sie sagten, sie wollten das
vermeiden  Bürokratie E  Europa, sie sind
ihnen nicht in den Sinn gekommen, die Bürokratie
Englands ist genauso schlimm wie die Bürokratie
anderswo, und warum sind sie begrenzt,
weil sie genug Erfahrung haben,
und so machen Sie weiter und Sie lernen die
ganze Zeit, und das ist, was ich  Ich meine
, wenn Sie neugierig sind, wenn Ihr Gehirn
aktiv ist, findet es interessante Dinge, und
was ich sage, ist in Ordnung, wir führen unser
Gespräch und eins zu eins, und
manchmal entsteht Freundschaft,
manchmal werden
Ehen zwischen Menschen geschlossen, die sich
zufällig treffen  Manchmal verbessert es
die Atmosphäre. Es ist nützlich für
Ausländer, die in unser Land kommen, um sich zu treffen.
Ich habe viel von Mördern gelernt,
die ich in diesem Gespräch getroffen habe
und sie töteten eines Tages und du
kennst das Gefängnis, in dem sie Java lesen und schreiben gelernt haben
Bär jetzt in der Nähe von
Monaghan Problem der S&M ist ein neuer Bamboo
Stream in Countys in der Nähe von Oklahoma hundert
flauschige
Vanessa Milde Bambusse auf diesem
Organismus China Pandabär und wird
wegen unseres Fernsehers über Canon so
Simlish Alice Essen in tödlicher Wunde in
unserem Konsulat in Confer Town in Kanada genannt
Gators katha nach Hause mrs.  Allan unsere
Angst markiert einen Streit auf seinem
höchsten Staatsbesuch.
Unser Englisch markiert unseren Artikel. Ja,
eines der Dinge,
über die jetzt alle reden, ist, wie man kreativ ist,
und alles, was vor Ort davon ausgeht, dass
Kreativität entsteht  aus dir heraus und
ist gut gut du kannst kreativ sein und
etwas Schlechtes produzieren Ich denke auch, dass
ich lieber über Fortpflanzung spreche,
was bedeutet, wenn zwei Menschen
einen Mann treffen und eine Frau ein
Kind hervorbringt und das Kind anders wird
als sie selbst  es ist immer nicht das, was
sie erwartet haben, obwohl Eltern in der Vergangenheit
versucht haben, die Kinder
genau das zu machen, was sie wollten, und es nicht geschafft hat
, und ich habe nie gesehen, dass
Musik eine Zusammenarbeit ist, und ich habe
daher über
das Individuum gesprochen, anstatt über das Individuum zu sprechen  das scheint ein
modernes Ideal zu sein, und anstatt
über das Kollektiv zu sprechen, was die
Alternative war, sprach ich von dem Paar, und
das Paar kann für mich nicht nur
zwei Personen sein  und du zu Menschen und du
zeugst etwas, weil ich mir
von dir ein Bild machen werde. Ich mag die Art
, wie du deine Fragen mit
ziemlich viel Humor gestellt hast, und es gibt keinen
Humor. Meditation Dalai Lama
Ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, Design hält mich,
ja, aber man muss ja, man muss
verschiedene Arten von Humor verstehen und
was ich immer versucht habe, in meinen Büchern zu studieren,
und ich habe damit in Frankreich begonnen, als
ich über Frankreich schrieb und versuchte,
den Humor zu verstehen  In anderen Ländern ist
der Humor verschiedener Kategorien von
Menschen und Menschen eine sehr komplizierte
Sache und oft böse,
manchmal satirisch, manchmal mitfühlend
und manchmal fantastisch wie Alice
im Wunderland und so weiter,
aber der Humor, der mich wirklich interessiert,
ist der Humor, der das entdeckt  Wahrheit,
die nicht getäuscht wird und nicht
mit mir kämpft. Könige hatten früher Narren, ja,
und der Narr pflegte dem König zu sagen,
was ihm sonst niemand sagen würde, und
er hatte die  die Erlaubnis, die Wahrheit zu sagen,
und er würde sagen, dieser Minister
wickelt Sie nur ein, um
etwas von Ihnen zu bekommen, und das war die
Wahrheit und beabsichtigte, Naranja, es gibt
einen Mangel daran, weil
es sehr gefährlich ist, offen die Wahrheit zu sagen
an deinen Vorgesetzten, blau zu sein,
kann dich jetzt kontrollieren, jeder sagt, du
darfst niemanden beleidigen, geschweige denn
eine Religion erwähnen, falls du
jemanden mit dieser Religion beleidigst, und
so versuchen wir, die Wahrheit unsichtbar zu machen,
und ich vergleiche die Wahrheit -  zu einem
diamanten ein diamant ist etwas was
viele verschiedene facetten hat und im laufe
der geschichte sind die schleifer von diamanten
immer besser und mehr
und mehr seiten zu den diamanten geworden und doch
jeder wirft das rechte licht auf eine
andere weise und nun wir  sind
Spezialisten in verschiedenen Berufen geworden, und
wir sehen die Wahrheit aus verschiedenen
Richtungen, und jeder sieht ein
bisschen Wahrheit, und mich interessiert
, was er von der Wahrheit hält  th, was
Sie von dem halten, was alle für die
Wahrheit halten, und einen Sinn daraus zu machen, ja,
Ice Club, eine Vendetta-Replik des Himmelssprays,
Treffen mit Richard Davidson Air Clubs,
unser Lieben über Stößel, Demenz,
Unterdrückung und iam Adityan Ziegler Moons,
frühes Eingreifen, Philadelphia Pacer,
wenn wir unter zurückkehren  Unterdrückung informieren
oh nein Akira Clayton dann ist Lee
Bendixson am größten auf Canons EF es ist besonders
Theodore Selden Ich sage nicht besser zu werden
Ich sage es wird anders sein ein
erfüllteres Leben du wirst entdecken was das Leben ist
und es könnte zurück sein  und es mag gut sein
aber das Leben ist immer eine Mischung du wirst
es nicht besser machen täusche
dich nicht ich bin KEIN Utopist auch zum
Glück die Praxis noch deutlicher
besagter Indikator siehe hier auf unseren nächsten de
Vaca Toren im
Schlittendesign Vita Allen Systems Van  Wenn
möglicherweise Smith
Philip ein Bar-Adenom kuzey Intifada
Ankara Austins estiga unterstellte Nächte fühlte,
kann ich eine Verlängerung des Rostov in
chirurgischem Floating düster bald löschen Tomatis
Person
Connie ver  sus Tier ein lauter Florentiner
Strampler, aber nach der Debatte über das Leben zu Hause
Suzanne Baumwolle gibt
Alfonzo ihre Website Angus-Krise Inder
Petraeus Berater Pyotr Polanski ihre
Trägheit kann indonesisch sein muss über
angespannt sein Dankeschön Gebühren Interesse an Danica
TiVo ihm
[Musik]
du